[Music]
welcome to the pretty intense podcast a
really interesting guest today I don't
have any children but this wonderful
woman Lindsay milis has delivered over
1500 of them she's been practicing since
2004 as a traditional spiritual Midwife
this is also known as Midwifery but
really today was a deep
historical education of the process of
growing a baby and having the baby and
how that's changed so much over the last
500 years and some of it was changed 500
years ago and it's still the way it is
right now which is not natural there's
so much not natural about the process so
we talked about everything from
circumcisions which is something she's
very passionate about not about I should
say food to the energetics to letting go
to infertility and and in so many
different aspects of it and then of
course just the modern medicine and and
what it's like to have a baby naturally
at home as she did Under the Stars
versus something where you're going to a
hospital and you might be getting a
C-section or you might be getting pumped
full of drugs that will dilate you and
and really taking away your power so
today's episode which I think is so
valuable for a man and a woman because
obviously there's so many men out there
that are fathers to really understand
what is happening with childbirth and
how important it is for a woman to go
through the natural process and to feel
and grow in her power and that there is
Magic in doing this right and doing it
the way it used to be done so long ago
of course modern medicine plays its role
but it doesn't need to play a role for
everyone all the time thank you for
listening please hit the Subscribe
button deeply appreciate that and of
course your comments and the bell for
notifications
element is a tasty electrolyte drink
with everything you need and nothing you
don't that means that there's lots of
salt and no sugar element is formulated
to help anyone with their electrolyte
needs and is perfectly suited to any
diet or lifestyle for me I drink element
all day every day I put it in just about
every single drop of water that I drink
for me it feels like it helps keep me
full it helps give me more energy and I
feel like water is absorbed better by
the body when it has element in it it
truly feels like magic to me receive a
free element sample pack with any order
when you use drinkelement.com pretty
intense that's drinkelement.com pretty
intense I think I wanted to start with
like the history like I think that was
what was so striking when we you left me
some voice notes and you were kind of
telling me about stuff I'm like oh [__]
people need to know the history of
childbirth of the process leading up up
to it that whole experience and then I
mean just giving birth itself feels like
something that modern science has really
twisted so like what is what is what is
the occult also known as hidden truth
about like what we don't know or what we
aren't remembering or taught about
burying a child and giving birth
yeah okay so I I really want to start
first with like a deep breath together
because I feel that as we move into this
topic and as we move into the energy of
this like us like women were like all
the time and like that's not where this
lies like this is like deep deep deep
within our bodies and so anybody that's
listening me and you like if we kind of
like really get into our bodies right
now and just take a nice Collective deep
breath together so breathing in through
our noses all the way down through our
lungs into our sacred wombs if you don't
have a womb you have that creative power
and just kind of feeling embodying this
moment because right now we're going to
move through some deep history some dark
history and also come back to this deep
remembering that we have within our
bones that we have within our DNA that's
back many many lineages of women that
have come before us
and so as we just settle into that
energy and just move away from the
fast-paced Modern Life we're able to
receive this energy better so the first
thing you know that we can kind of move
into with that hidden energy that birth
brings is that it used to not be hidden
and it's something that throughout all
of time women have known the power that
comes from birth
the power that comes from birth is
something that I'm really familiar with
right like I've attended over 1500 women
in their power I've seen
um the portal like basically I call
myself the portal people keeper like I
I'm in between worlds most times
and it's this deep transformative power
that comes from within that we basically
say that we can't do it anymore and in
that moment we get a tap back down into
a strength that we never even knew that
we had and do it and so it's this power
it's this mystery it's this thing that
can't be controlled it's sensual it's
sexual it's ecstatic it's hard it's you
know it takes us to the the depth of the
end of the universe and back into our
bodies like I always say we have to go
to the Stars to retrieve our babies and
so when that is placed into a box when
that's placed into a check box when
that's placed into a hospital when
that's placed into a book that Western
medicine says this is how it's done and
this is how we do it it takes away all
that magical reverence that comes with
it and so you know I I always say like
I'm not all or nothing like I'm not a
person that stands on on one side of the
Jensen says like we don't need that like
no I know there's a time and a place
always for Western medicine like you
know it's it's one of those things that
throughout the last 23 years of my life
like I've I've used it many times but
appropriately
and childbirth is a normal physiological
process so in my practice uh you know I
can look at like the C-section rates as
a comparison here so
um we can go anywhere from hospitals
that have really good C-section rates at
around 25
to a hospital down the road from me that
has a C-section rate of around 50 what
should it be
so if you take out all of the new high
risk like IVF women being pregnant over
the age of 45 like all these other
things that kind of come into play the
World Health Organization recommends
that it sit anywhere around 15 percent
in my practice and I have low risk women
so I know that there's a different
variation here I maybe get to around
four percent per year maybe
so there's a big difference in that
statement right like you're you're
looking at somebody who has a four
percent cesarean rate and who has women
that have
wildly transformational experiences
where they lock eyes with me at the end
of their experience and tell me that it
completely changed their lives
to a woman that has a cesarean that's
laid flat on an operating bed in the
middle of an operating room with you
know Bright Lights cold temperature
people talking 15 people in the room and
it completely takes away from that
spiritual experience that comes with
birth now I've had both experiences my
daughter was a C-section which is what
prompted me to get into childbirth and
then my son was born in my backyard in
my jacuzzi underneath the Stars so I
know personally the difference of those
two experiences
and so that's where we gonna kind of get
to come back to this place of
remembering right like yeah yeah not
everybody has to give birth at home I
don't give a [__] if you give birth at
home but what I want you to know is that
you get a habit transformative
experience even if it's in the hospital
and you you get to know that there are
certain things that you get to ask for
in order for that to happen and in order
for the birth process to happen in a way
that it's not controlled so I had my
daughter super young right I was 21
years old I was already in healthcare I
was working in a hospital and I just
went along with what everybody did
during the surgery I actually felt
everything the anesthesia wasn't working
properly so I was like like actually
thinking that my insides were getting
ripped open and I've had countless women
that have messaged me and been like oh
my God the anesthesia wasn't working for
me I felt everything too so I know it's
an experience that women have yeah and
all of my power was stripped I was tied
to a bed you know like my arms were like
crucified on both sides and I was tied
to a bed as I was waiting for this baby
to come into my arms
now I asked to be put to sleep during
that surgery just because it was there
was so much pain but when I woke up I
laid eyes on my daughter and completely
fell in the deepest love I've ever felt
in my whole entire life I know that's
not a common experience I know there's a
lot of women that have the experience of
being so out of body during the surgical
experience that they're kind of like out
of it who's that baby like oh my gosh I
know I'm supposed to bond with this baby
but I'm not really bonding with this
baby I feel like [__]
um but I I just you know I grabbed her
and basically never let go of her we had
amazing parenting together I parented
you know she was what we call attachment
parenting like she was breastfed and she
was in a sling all the time and she
slept right next to me and I was attuned
to her every need
and I I knew in that moment and you know
with the months passing that something
had been robbed for me like there was an
innate rite of passage that was actually
taken from me and I couldn't put it into
a word and I couldn't
describe it to anybody else but it was
this knowing that I had within my soul
that something was missing
and so I started just rocking through
information and that was back in 2002 so
you know like Google was kind of a new
thing back then and I was like there has
to be some way for me did not like be in
this experience ever again but also to
help women not have the same experience
that I just had
so I you know was like did the right
thing like I went to like become a
childbirth educator and I taught
childbirth classes in the hospital and
then I became a doula and a doula
somebody that's a little bit different
than a midwife so midwives are providing
medical care for that women for that
family throughout their whole entire
pregnancy into the birth and through the
postpartum period a doula is someone
that's there specifically for physical
and emotional support so they're still
there giving you really good information
but they're not there in the medical
aspect
um they don't have like the liability so
to speak of what what midwives do
so I became a doula and I was working in
the hospital and every time I went to a
birth in the hospital I was horrified I
was like what is going on everything I'm
doing it doesn't even matter like it
there's nothing that I'm changing I felt
like an actual accomplice to a crime in
most situations like I was sitting in a
room watching all of these horrific
things happening sitting on my hands one
thing specifically that stood out to me
was how babies were treated at Birth
and so what I saw is these babies where
the cord was cut and they were whisked
away into a warmer away from their mom
um I I'm going to give you a little
brief lesson on normal physiological
cord closure so what the first thing
that you think of when you are watching
a movie or a TV show like or like
someone's giving birth in the back of an
ambulance what's the first thing that
they call for
cord clamp right like how do we cut the
cord what do we do with the card
and now I want you to imagine like a
farm right there's goats there's cows
there's horses you're watching any
mammal over the whole entire world give
birth
and and it's really interesting to think
that we think that we need a device for
something that has worked perfectly for
however many years right like birth is
intended to work or we wouldn't be here
today there is no farm animal there is
no mammal that is born with the baby
holding a cord clamp saying please clamp
my cord okay and so when we stop that
process the baby actually is born into a
state of physiological shock they lose
their blood supply that is actually
theirs and stored in the placenta so
automatically right away they're like
what is this world my blood supply is
gone it's cold it's bright where's my
mom what's this oxygen for the first
time what's this oxygen yeah like
they're actually moving the fluid
through their lungs for their first four
or five breaths in order to even get
oxygen into their lungs so all of that
is happening and super this fast-paced
way and then they're you know away from
their mom and they're under these bright
lights and so all of us are starting
life in a state of physiological shock
right
and so when I saw this happening like I
said I felt like an accomplished to a
crime because I'm like this isn't how it
has to be and I really didn't even know
much other than this birth because
that's the only birth that I had seen up
into that point so then I started my
quest for like uh get me out of here
like I need something else yeah one of
my mentors was like I'm starting uh one
of the first Midway free schools in
California you should join and I was
like okay like let's let's do this and
so I started that process and in the
middle of the process I was pregnant
with my son and
um then I was seeing normal
physiological bursts at home because
part of the schooling is also going in
and mentoring another Midwife in the
community and getting all of your
numbers and hours in for for your
licensure so to speak
and that's how it was through all of
time apprenticeship was always the way
that midwives worked yeah um and so you
know I'm I'm in this space of knowing
that things can be totally different and
so that's the energy that I took into my
son's birth now trust me there were
still things I had to work through that
were deeply ingrained into my soul that
uh you know the trust system so like
first of all you're becoming a mother
either for the first time second time
third time whatever but you're becoming
a new mother to this baby right so this
is this is a new aspect of parenting
you've never parented this trial before
if you have any mother wounds if you
have any father wounds those things are
going to come up and burn which we all
do which we all do even if you have the
greatest parent in the world right
exactly and it's so so those things are
very apparent either throughout the
prenatal process or throughout the birth
and even if you've thought that you've
done a lot of work throughout the
prenatal process it like you know like
really clearing through all that trauma
like it tends to kind of show its face
if if there's something there another
thing that I've seen come up and this
wasn't my experience but if you've had
any sexual abuse in the past so one in
three women are supposed to be have had
some sort of sexual abuse in their
lifetime now I have a really in-depth
question here when I go through all of
my clients and on there it says like
even if you don't feel comfortable in
this moment just please know that any
sort of sexual abuse can make its way
into your birth here are some resources
maybe wait and see a couple of months
and see if you feel comfortable sharing
this experience with me it's on the
table they know that that's something
that's on the table and
there's times where no one has discussed
it with me and I know immediately if
there's sexual abir sexual abuse in a
birth and the husbands look at me like
how did you know that and it's like
there's certain things that women say
because you're losing complete control
you're going into a Divine surrender but
if you've lost control before of your
sexuality it's usually not in the best
sense of the word so it kind of
replicates how the abuse happens so like
there's there's there's women that sound
like
uh you know if they were if they had
sexual abuse when they were five they
kind of go back and revert back to this
end of being five
um it's it's I mean it shakes you to
your core to witness it I moved through
my birth with my son I had a beautiful
labor it was relatively quick for all
things considered it was the middle of
summer it was hot we were in and out of
the pool all day and then like I said he
was born under the stars in my jacuzzi
so I left that experience like
completely
recalibrated to my core like I was like
oh this is the rite of passage that I
missed out on and that postpartum
experience was totally different in a
sense that not that I didn't have any
problems bonding with my daughter and I
was you know super bonded to my son but
I knew in that moment that I could do
anything and that has carried with me
through the rest of my life so is it the
difference between being in a situation
where you're at the hospital and they
are doing a lot of the work or they're
medicating you and they're sort of like
there's too much intervention with the
process that when you're doing it at
home
it's like someone telling you you need
to go do some crazy workout you're like
I don't know I don't know if I can do
that and then you push through and you
get done you're like yes and you feel so
strong it's like you've actually done it
you're you don't even know how you're
gonna do it but you go and you come out
of it because you actually had to do a
lot more work you had to go into
yourself which is why when you get
squeezed the worst comes out right
that's where the truth comes out I say
worse but it's really just like the
wounds and all that and so it's because
it's harder right I mean I mean am I
getting that wrong I mean it's a little
rewarding it's right on or connective
but it's harder and you have to have
confidence you have to trust the people
around you you have to trust yourself
you have to be able to let go you have
to be able to push through pain you have
to be able to breathe through things you
have to be able to go to another place
sometimes probably that's why you come
out of that so much more empowered and
Powerful is because you're in your power
you finally start to realize some of
your potential as a human being yeah I
mean it's liking it too like if you were
to go run a marathon and you you did all
this training and then they're like
we're gonna give you an epidural and
you're going to be numb through the
entire experience yeah and when you
cross that Finish Line it wouldn't be
the same as you having to push yourself
at that last you know three mile Mark at
that like you know at the 15 Mile Mark
where you're like oh my God I can't go
any further no kidding and so if you
compare the two like that it's like oh
well that makes sense
um now again there's always a time and a
place for you know an epidural or a
C-section but like the majority of
births are supposed to be unintervened
with uncontrolled and allowed to happen
normally a lot of things that we see
right now is it with induction so
induction of birth is where we actually
start to give medication to ripen the
cervix to open the cervix and to have
contractions to birth a baby and then I
always like to look at a flower right if
you were to sit and watch a little bud
and it was starting to open and we
started to peel back every single petal
right forcing it to open what would it
look like right
wouldn't it be ready it just wouldn't be
ready no and it would look like a floppy
flower right and so it's the same thing
that like once we start thinking that we
can like force this thing to open and we
can go in and like you know Force
dilation and force contractions like we
don't know what we're missing out on we
don't know what the the potential of
that beautiful blossoming flower would
be if we just left it alone right well
there's that I'm actually really curious
because
it feels like and again I have no
children my sister has four
um like I've heard about stuff and all
my friends have kids but for the most
part but tell me what the tell me what
the trade-off is between waiting for the
flower to open versus it feels like
there's a lot of women that decide to
schedule a birth like would there what's
the reason why you would schedule and
like why like what should what is the
trade-off like what what are you
sacrificing by saying I'm going to plan
this versus wait for it like what what
do you need to be ready for if you'd
make that kind of decision for yourself
and your baby yeah so obviously there's
medical reasons for induction right but
stepping outside of that all it does is
it comes back to this level of control
when we think we control something we
miss out on all of the magic all of the
mystery all of the transformation that
comes with that Divine surrender
so this is something that like it's not
we're not supposed to know like if I
knew when babies were going to be born
my life would be so much easier right
like I wouldn't be up at three o'clock
in the morning and I wouldn't have done
this interview like four months ago
sorry two babies are coming today yeah
and so it's you know we just live in a
culture that we just can't jump into
that Divine surrender and it's it's
something that like it's a really
important piece to have it's a really
important thing that we
gather into moving through the rest of
our lives because I mean really do we
really control anything like like do we
like you know people birth and death are
on the same end of the spectrum you know
one's over here and one's over here but
like we don't know when we're gonna die
you know like it's it's like you we
could get in the car and like tomorrow
everything's over and so it's it's like
really being in that reverent space that
um we get to be in a state of surrender
I think this is an easy like transition
to talking a lot about the energy of
growing the baby having the baby
connection with the baby I mean we could
go and I want to also go into like
things like infertility and like how the
energy works with all of this stuff so
what are some of the main issues that
come up with the women that you're
working with and probably has to do with
also the men right like because it's all
connected
um but what are some of the main things
that come up for these women where you
give them energetic Direction the basis
of my Foundation of how I practice comes
from the association of pre and
perinatal psychology and health their
website's birthpsychology.org and
they've been around for a long time like
that the heads of this organization for
forever were you know like these like 70
75 year old women and men that have been
like begging the medical community to
wake up to knowing that the baby is
aware and that the baby is a conscious
being and that the mother and baby are
one unit and
um you know I mentioned my Hospital
experience of these babies being whisked
away and that's really why I came into a
home birth practice is because I wanted
to welcome babies in a much different
way and not to say that Mom's experience
of birth isn't equally as important but
they're they're you know they are
they're one unit and it's really
important how we navigate through
preconception conception into the
prenatal process through the birth and
then into the postpartum period because
you know this is our future generation
and and we know that if babies are
brought into a world that's full of
stress
um that you know moms are in a prenatal
period of of just sitting and nothing
but fear or you know 2020 is a perfect
example here right so
um I've I've been witnessing births for
almost 20 years and when 2020 happened
and the world shut down like I know you
can kind of liken it to a war or
something it's really scary because
nobody really knew what was going on in
the beginning
and so I had these moms and remember
these are moms that are seeking
something that's totally natural they're
in a home Birth Midwifery practice and
they have direct access to their care
provider to move through their fears and
stress okay so this is like way above
what is normal for what the majority of
women were experiencing during 2020.
yeah I have never in my entire life seen
the outcomes the
experiences that those babies were
coming into the world with and I'm like
these babies are just literally stewing
and this amniotic fluid that is full of
cortisol and they are like they're like
do I really want to come to the world at
this time and these babies would be born
and I mean they they you know would come
into their bodies but like you would see
them look around the room and there's
this special moment where they kind of
lock eyes and lock energy with different
people that are their welcoming
committee is what I call it the sacred
welcoming committee and so many times
we're talking about energies in the room
right we're talking about right like
well it was something that they can see
is sort of in the field that we don't
have the we have blocked out or we have
taught herself to Nazi we've blocked it
out and then and then these these babies
come in and they're like
do do I want to be here like your fault
is it your fault yeah am I here yeah and
and so you know I I made it a purpose
and I and I'm thankful that this hasn't
played out over the last year in my
practice but like almost every single
baby I was like you chose to come now we
need you now you need to breathe we
breathe air here we breathe air into our
lungs and we are so grateful that you
chose now to come and like with those
few words you could see them kind of
like okay maybe this is where we want to
be right now and but they were all slow
to start they you know they took a while
to like take their first breath like I
you know I used a lot of like Sound
Energy sometimes like okay like this is
the earth you're here this is your body
like you're outside yeah I mean those
are things that like you know guides
during like medicine ceremonies will do
they have feathers they have you know
sounds they have drums they have all
kinds of things and I always feel like
it's to ground you it's to like go your
here first remember connect you to
connect you to Earth yeah yep and so
that's you know like that was what I was
doing it was it you know the the whole
world was on an Ayahuasca journey in
2020 but these babies were as well and
so everybody that was ushering in these
babies were the the shamans that had to
freaking ground them into their bodies
yeah you were a shaman for sure yeah
yeah so it's it's
it's interesting because like I said now
that's shifted a little bit so we're not
in this Perpetual state of fear and
what's going to drop next I mean I'm
sure there are some people that are
still living in that state of fear but
um now I'm like oh these babies are
coming in as Warriors you know like like
they're like oh I'm here like I'm gonna
tell you that I'm here right yeah what
do you think about the idea that um
because you know for people that are
like down the spiritual path there's
like you know the waves of volunteers
and the indigo children and crystal
children
um and someone explained it to me where
basically the the planet's frequency is
is changing it's it's rising it's uh and
so each Incarnation like the the
children that are born into that
frequency are already loaded with that
new frequency yeah so they already
they've already had the download yes and
that when the the the generations before
just weren't born born into that
frequency so they just takes a lot more
they might never get there
um what do you think about that oh I
totally agree with that and I can see it
like it's something that's palpable in
the room
um even with the difference of a couple
years from 2020 to now like the
difference of the energy of these babies
is I call them like light Warriors like
they are super high vibration but they
are strong and they are like we are not
gonna take any more of these
generational curses like this this like
lineage [__] that's been in our family's
history for the past you know few
Millennials it's done like no more of
this no more victimhood like we're here
to elevate
um and that's that's totally what I'm
feeling and I'm covered in Goosebumps as
I say it because it's something that I
just you know I'm in the energy of Allah
and I'm just super grateful to see this
shift and change with that yeah I had a
cool experience where my mom's mom
passed away and she kind of came through
and some Bodywork stuff that I was doing
some somatic stuff within body work and
yeah those are some of the things like
I've I've always I've felt like there's
like an ancestral role to play but she
was like you're the one we've been
waiting for to like break this
codependency curse with men and and
self-sacrifice and and not not being
Sovereign in our power and
um and so I feel that like I feel I've
felt that so deeply so maybe that's like
an interesting place to go into before
we go into that really quick I like want
to honor that because I want like
everybody that's listening to really
take another deep breath and embody that
because that's the the common message
that I keep hearing and you just had
this beautiful affirmation of it like we
and these babies being born are the
the souls that our ancestors have been
waiting for truly like like we really
get a step out of this victimhood we
really get a step out of this
codependence and we really get to step
into Sovereign beings yeah yeah I think
that in thank you yeah
to say yes right it's to say yes it's to
not be afraid it's to part of me thinks
that when you're here to do something
you're here to do it and
um there's no other way but it still
takes a little conviction to go no no
I feel like I'm always like it's me
listening to have you ever heard of
Dolores Cannon
like she's passed away but she's a
hypnotherapist and she would always I'd
listen to so many hours of Dolores and
she would say you know if you get you
get it wrong you got to come back again
and do it maybe you'll flip positions
maybe you'll be the guy instead of the
girl or whatever it is and I'm like all
I keep thinking is like I'm not gonna
come back and do it again not gonna get
all the way to 35 or 40 or whatever my
age is to have to learn this lesson I'm
gonna get it right this time I don't
know how far into sort of ancestral
memory you get and like
um also
um the imprinting that the Mom has on
the baby with even things like
um the food choices they make or the
thoughts that they have the viruses that
they get during whatever like how is
that all imprinting the baby so let's
start first with food as medicine right
so anything that is entering our bodies
ever but especially during pregnancy is
basically a a medicine a light code if
you will of what gets to be the genetic
imprint of our babies we know you know
Joe dispenza you have Bruce Lipton all
of these people that come in and are so
aligned with like saying like you know
genes can be turned on genes can be
turned off but it's also like
epigenetics yes and it's also the power
that we have with our thought and so
um you know obviously like nutrition is
one of the most important pieces of the
care that I give and that is making sure
that the woman is taking care of
themselves you know like you're you're
housing a baby you're not only housing a
baby you've grown an organ that feeds
this baby and uh you know we we know
that with with poor nutrition with poor
choices smoking drinking all of those
things that it it the house isn't it's
either like a palace or it's like a
shack and so we obviously want to make
the right choices to house our babies in
a really good
um space and so
um you know that's something that's
talked about but I you know when we go
back into the imprinting of uh
throughout all of history you know like
chances are that maybe your grandma or
great grandma was raised during the
Great Depression and they were eating
junk canned food unless they were on a
farm or something you know
um and uh you know these these periods
of famine
um indeed mineralization if you will are
also part of that story and so
um as we move more into the quantum
field we really get to make the choice
to deprogram that from from where we're
at and
um you know make those decisions that
creates a better environment for our
babies to be grown in what about the
field around like emfs
you know telephones Wi-Fi Bluetooth ear
Bluetooth watch like is there any
recommendations you have with what you
when you're working with women to
eliminate yeah I mean I wish this was
studied more but obviously it's not and
um yeah I mean I recommend like put a
timer on your Wi-Fi in your house please
don't wear the the EMF watches the Apple
watches the fitbits I had one mom that
she pulled up her shirt and she had a
Fitbit attached to the inside of her
underwear like literally right next to
the baby's head I was like oh my God
take that off right now you know and so
we just don't know the effects we don't
know the long-term effects of this this
is all new I mean it's within our you
know I mean I went to high school and
had a pager there wasn't even a cell
phone back then so we just don't have
the long-term studies with it but I I
can tell you that my knowing my deep you
know womb knowing is that we should
avoid those as much as possible while
growing a baby while raising a baby you
know like screen free kids is a really
good thing like you know we're not like
raising these zombies that are like
staring down at their phones 24 7.
um getting out in nature getting our
feet in the dirt you know it's those are
all really important things that that
was always in place you know for all of
our ancestors we never they never had
any of these modern days yeah what about
a mom and her thing like oh it's so
important so a big piece of of my
practice is yeah you can see right here
there's a door behind me and
um my my room is I call it the therapy
room too so if I have somebody that
comes in here that needs a good cry
needs a good grounding needs a good
earthing we go straight out the back
door like it's it's part of prenatal
care and we take our shoes off and we
put our feet into that dirt and we root
down you know through everything
underneath us into the core of the earth
and
um we spend time and breath together and
we you know bring up up that energy and
just kind of return back to that that
normal cycle that we've had a part of
our daily living for for so long what is
the recommended amount of weight to gain
during pregnancy so I try to take the
numbers out of it
um you'll see anywhere from like 25 to
35 pounds is a normal amount of weight
to gain and now in my practice I have
the cream of the crop right like people
are coming in already Health Savvy
because they're choosing home birth so I
don't like say count calories or weigh
yourself or do this or that I basically
say eat intuitively like I want you to
listen to your body in this moment and
like you know like if you feel like you
need to have a steak go have a steak if
you feel like you need to go and have
like aloe vera juice to you know have
you know good movement within your
intestines go do that like there's just
so many things that
um because the women coming in already
have a previous typically have a
previous knowledge of of nutrition that
they they get to be really intuitive
what they're eating and you look I mean
gosh you can see all the celebrities
they're like you know I'm craving
McDonald's or I'm like eating Slurpees
and you're like that's such a [__]
that's because you've starved yourself
your entire life and now this is your
opportunity to overeat and indulge isn't
it the truth isn't it yeah and it's like
that's just crazy like you're growing a
baby let's go back to that house that
you're creating for this baby it doesn't
need Slurpees this is like the original
I don't know how I mean I've done a lot
of inner child work and I literally try
and look at my inner child like my child
because it helps me make better
decisions because I can self-sacrifice
on myself but if this was literally my
child my daughter I would never let
someone treat her that way I would never
feed her that I would never do that to
her like I would never let someone
continue to do something that was
damaging or emotionally distressful like
I just wouldn't right and so you know
that is but you're actually when you're
pregnant truly with with your child
you're not using it as sort of like an
imaginary sort of scenario it's truly
happening so why would you feed your dog
your daughter or son Popeyes why would
you feed them you know 48 ounces of
Coca-Cola like why would you why would
you do those things
um do you find that the women that
um sort of go off the deep end like that
do they which you probably don't see
that much of but you have seen a lot I'm
sure so is does that lead to
um
overweight children do they have does it
become imprinted on them or is it maybe
more of like just that all of a sudden
they're in that environment still
I mean you know again there's not a lot
a whole lot of research on it so what do
I think I think that there's definitely
the potential there for it right like if
you're creating those habits in utero
that's an imprint that is a primal
cellular imprint into that child and
then most of the time they're coming out
into that same imprints you know like
it's it's it's the same environment same
pattern that's created again and yeah
you know you see there was one celebrity
uh who you could you know she was you
following them seeing them post all
these pictures and I'm like towards the
end of a pregnancy I'm like oh she's got
preeclampsia and everybody's like how do
you know I'm like I she she has
preeclampsia and the next one
preeclampsia is a condition of pregnancy
where it's elevated blood pressure the
liver starts to get out of whack I mean
it's it's a medical problem
um it's a reason to induce for labor and
you know this particular celebrity was
induced three days later for
preeclampsia I was like well no [__] of
course she has pre-eclampsia you know I
can spot it a mile away
um but but it goes back to I'm sure the
nutritional choices that she made
throughout her pregnancy or crap so if
you're not nourishing your body if
you're not getting the protein if you're
not you know getting that good water
you're not grounding you're not moving
that's what's gonna happen what about
the
sort of recommendations that doctors
have had in the past of like don't have
deli meat don't have sushi all that is
that I mean is there a lot of validity
to that or not based in liability
all based on liability so you know you
look at Japan do you think there's women
that aren't eating sushi everybody's
floating totally right if you look back
uh still like if you look at any Amish
farmers they're all drinking raw milk
pregnant all of your grandmas great
grandmas great great grandmas were all
drinking raw milk straight from the cow
and so when we have these
recommendations that
um you know the doctors say don't do
this don't do that it's just to release
themselves from liabilities so do I mean
is there potential for things that could
happen yeah but there's Potential from
you getting sick from eating spinach so
let's Choose Wisely like where are your
sources coming from are you trusting the
places that you're getting your your
foods from
um so you know the majority of my
clients are are drinking raw milk and
having sushi and you know they're
they're being intuitive with their
bodies
let's get into like the sticky and talk
about vaccines oh we're gonna go there
okay we have to go there I think we have
to go there there's too much about it
there's too much there's too much
curiosity there's too much awareness
coming out about it you know one of my
colleagues and good friends in the
medical field is Dr Robert Sears he is
two exits down the freeway from me you
know we're really close in proximity and
really close uh as spiritual companions
through this life
and he said it best recently and he's
always in trouble so you know I I I do
try to avoid topics that are like
you know the Hot Topic because there's
there's persecution you know like like
one of the things I want to talk about
is like the the burning of witches and
it's like no this this is still the
burning of witches here and so we we
share a lot of common clients I call
them clients some people will call them
patients and what he said is that um in
his practice he's been practicing
Pediatrics for 25 years
he has released a book called The
vaccine book he's done a lot of research
um and he has a client base where when
he started the majority of his clients
were questioning some you know vaccine
choices
um and and then as his practice evolved
everybody kind of saw him as the the
pediatrician that would accept them you
know a lot of Pediatricians if they're
controlled by the insurance companies
will say hey we can't see you in our
office like you need to find another
pediatrician and so he was the
pediatrician with open doors that said
you know I'm here to welcome you with
the choices that you're making for your
children as a responsible adult making
autonomous choices based in best
benefits risks and Alternatives and here
are those benefits risks and
Alternatives and what he found is that
most people these you know decided not
to adhere to the CDC
you know it's different there's it's
it's it's always changing but the
recommendations that change every year
and what he saw is that in a practice
that should have had a lot of children
that were really sick from diseases that
we're vaccinating from were were
children that were actually really
really healthy and if they did contract
some of these you know pertussis
whooping cough type things that their
immune systems were able to support them
in a way where they yeah they got sick
but they none of them had died
so statistically speaking it doesn't
really line up and so he you know he
what he also has seen on the contrary is
people that have come to him because of
injuries that have been had and he's
watched those children recover and then
parents make choices outside of what
they did the first time because they had
seen an injury and you know pivoted to
not have the same experience for future
for future children and so it's just one
of those
um
things that if we we look at the numbers
with you know and granted it's a small
pediatric practice but it still is is
it's relevant and it it's you know and
and like I said we share these clients
and so a lot of people choose home birth
because they don't want to have the same
experience that they had before which
could involve injured children for
someone because it's got to be a
personal decision intuitive do what
feels right for you go do your research
like where would you point where would
you point what direction would you point
people in to do that research to make
that decision for themselves yes so it's
definitely a personal decision and it's
something that I always say like always
always use informed consent while making
those decisions like it's not a
one-size-fits-all medicine in general is
not one size fits all it should always
be individualized
um Bob is a really good place to start
so the vaccine book you can get on
Amazon
um him and one of my former clients
Melissa Floyd did a podcast called the
vaccine conversation I think it's the
vaccine conversation.org I'll have to
double check on it but they have hours
and hours and hours and hours of
recorded information
specifically we could even talk about we
there's a bill coming up in California
that's going to require all 13 year old
boys and girls to get the HPV vaccine to
enter school and so they had a big
conversation about the benefits risks
and Alternatives of the HPV vaccine so
there's just a lot of movement within
that right now and it's it's really
you know like it's it's it's pretty
censored
um and so there's you can definitely
find information out there but you have
to to look at the right places so I I
would think the vaccine conversation
podcast would be the perfect place to
start
did I hear something when I was
listening to some things prepping about
still bursts and an increase in
stillbursts in recent time
so the numbers aren't out all the way
yet but what we're starting to see is
anywhere uh up to an increase of
stillbursts of 1700
since 2020. nobody knows I mean people
have their their own conclusions but
there's nothing that has been you know
in the medical community that says this
is what's causing it also last week
uh we had our release of information
about maternal mortality so there's
infant mortality and maternal mortality
and maternal mortality went up 40 from
2020 to 2021. 40
there's a lot of um medical racism if
you will there's there's disparities
within different communities that the
you know the I think it's 42.8 per 100
000 women that die or black compared to
12.1 that are white
um don't quote me on those exact
statistics but I think that's what it is
um and there's so many different ways
that we can look at this but
40 and 17 years
like are you kidding me easy numbers
they're crazy in numbers and and you
know like our infant mortality rate Cuba
has a better infant mortality rate than
the United States what is going on is
there really population control going on
is there like what the [__] is going on
because
things are not sensical like these are
incredibly scary statistics I mean you
know you hear you know Bill Gates say
that we need population control and then
you hear Elon Musk say we are running
out of like we there's not enough people
yeah we're gonna we're this is a problem
and I can see it from that side because
I mean here I am I'm 40 like I'm not
having children like women are having
them later people are generally having
less kids I think yeah there's men have
men are have more erectile dysfunction
have a lower uh fertility rates I mean I
think the testosterone Ray has dropped
70 percent yeah like that's a
significant huge thing there's a doctor
that talks about the the um shrinking of
the perineum the taint is what it's
known as and every year that the space
in between our as women are perineum in
between our vagina and our anus and then
as men in between the testicles and
their anus is shrinking every year
there's actually something called micro
penises now micro penises like don't
come across one thank God but you know
well it but you know I have in my
practice like I had my ultrasound tech
message me and be like this penis is
really small and I was like shut up like
what are you talking about and I mean
the baby came out with a micro penis and
this is a mom that takes really good
care of herself so where where is that
coming from you know like like is it the
Plastics is it the the phytoestrogens is
it the glycipate that's being sprayed
all over every freaking thing even if
you eat organic you know it's in
everything uh the seed oils that were
like what is it what is it you know
there's It's a combination of all the
things is it one thing who knows
now before we get off of totally
um children I thought I just wanted to
ask about circumcision one of the topics
that I am most passionate about actually
when I worked in the hospital I had an
office next to the newborn nursery
and I remember the first day that I
heard the scream of a newborn baby boy
that was being circumcised it printed to
the depth of my soul I will never forget
it it still makes everything in my body
every every ounce of my soul stand up
and say that I will always be the voice
of newborn baby boys that don't have a
voice
so let's look at World circumcision
rates right we are we are barely anybody
circumcised in the world like we're at
80 of the world that's not circumcised
okay you're 40 I'm 41. when we were
growing up right everybody was
circumcised I mean if you had like one
friend I had you know a friend John who
was from Argentina he wasn't circumcised
and everybody knew everybody in America
for sure yeah everybody knew that there
was one friend who had a baby and she
you know the other day she came home a
couple weeks ago and
because he got circumcised that day and
yeah yeah so now in the United States
that's that's as a whole the United
States has dropped under 50 for
circumcision
um in the western states in the western
states we're right around 20
um because a lot of insurance companies
are not covering it because it's now
being dubbed a cosmetic procedure
because it is okay so there is no
medical benefit the American Academy of
Pediatrics sticks their head in the sand
they actually posted a graphic when they
release their circumcision statement
probably 15 years ago and it was a bird
with its head in the sand okay stop it
yeah so what we know is that Dr Kellogg
Kellogg cereal brought circumcision to
the United States back in the late 1800s
and a lot of and [__] sugar for
breakfast well yeah among a million
other things right and what he said is
that this there's this puritanical
belief system that if we circumcise eyes
boys they wouldn't masturbate back then
they thought that masturbation led to
Insanity okay so the basis I mean I know
there's religious reasons I get that
like I'm not not talking about that okay
the basis of westernized medical
circumcision is based on the Assumption
of Dr Kellogg who told us that guys
wouldn't masturbate now we know that's
not [__] true right like come on like
they're not we're not talking about
Kellogg's cereal are we yeah okay yeah
okay I was like wait a second I heard
Kellogg and there's one picture okay
yeah so Dr Kellogg brought this
information in now we could go into the
spirituality of this right if we are to
take a newborn baby boy out of the arms
of a brand new mother and take it
somewhere and cut off the most sensitive
part of its body
right there you have just dubbed control
of that mother in her parenting
relationship right
like let that sink in like like it is so
unmaternal to let anybody harm your baby
but to have a medical professional come
in and say that you have to to do this
and cut off the most sensitive part of
its body that right there asserts
control within the medical system
immediately
okay so you know I could talk about the
subject for hours and hours and hours in
my practice my circumcision rate is
maybe two percent at the most and it's
usually for religious reasons
um it's something that needs to be a
conversation that's had on a regular
basis it needs to be a cultural shift
there is no reason that we should be
performing a medical procedure that has
a risk of death on a newborn baby a
death yes they can bleed to death from
this they can have they can have
mutations there can be Scar Tissue there
can be you know like the Crooked penis
you know everybody like there's some of
the people always talk about the grade
penis it's Scar Tissue that's pulling
their penis to the side
yeah so it's it's definitely something
that people should reevaluate
um you know out of pocket now it's
around 600 and so a lot of people are
choosing to not make that decision but
it shouldn't be because of a monetary
reason it should be because our bodies
are perfect and our baby boys are born
whole and there is no reason to uh you
know it's this it's the same thing as
female circumcision in my eyes there's
zero difference like you know everybody
is all up in arms about female
circumcision now what's female
circumcision so female circumcision is
most common in Africa it's and it's uh
typically done at a certain age in
African tribes and it's either uh when
they're closing together the labia are
cutting off the labia it's definitely on
like a conversation shift because for me
it would seem like like a boy just
doesn't want to be different than his
friends he doesn't want to like it seems
there's like a perception of it being
more dirty or something like that
yeah yeah it's I mean it's not it's
there's no difference than a a man
pulling his foreskin back and cleaning
his penis than us cleaning our vagina in
the shower like it's the same thing it's
true you know it's truly true yeah you
know that the The Gates Foundation is
behind the circumcision uh in Africa
they say that it prevents HIV they were
going around and circumcising a bunch of
Africans I mean how would that prevent
HIV I mean you you can lie with
Statistics any way you want right like
they're saying that it reduced the it's
actually transmitted diseases well let's
talk about condoms how about we go and
give out condoms instead I was in Egypt
and stop stop stop look at the car stop
it stop it okay well obviously you know
I had to ask this question
just how the world Works literally I
just [__] picked the card up like
right now
don't believe in energy and you don't
believe in the universe and all this
stuff like you're missing it um okay
when I was in Egypt on the walls they
um
one of the one of some of the higher
hieroglyphics set showed basically what
they were saying was childbirth and how
women would kind of sit and like gravity
would the baby would squat out yeah and
it would be a far more you know natural
process even like when you go to other
countries and the toilet is in the
ground in your squat like it's you know
and here in America we have a you know
squatty potty potty let's put our feet
up and yeah so it's kind of
ergonomically correct and they said that
it was
man that wanted to watch this and be
part of it and see this that women were
then laid down so that the man could
sort of like watch the process happen
and be there or see it in a way that
they like to see it yeah
um that that things were changed is
there any truth to that is there any
truth the way a baby's born has best put
into it like just twisted and flipped
and turned and laid on a bed the wrong
way yeah so it we need to look back a
couple hundred years prior to even
talking about women laying flat to give
birth
so throughout all of time birth was
attended by midwives men weren't allowed
there's a wonderful book called The Red
Tent that described the experience of
how women would Gather in these red
tents and you know they would menstrate
together and it was all of their sisters
and their aunties and their grandmothers
and they would share these experiences
together and you bet your ass when they
were in labor they would go back and be
surrounded by these women and of course
there was women that had more knowledge
of birth and they were probably out
collecting the different herbs in the
field uh that they knew would assist
with you know the mom having an easy
birth and you know I want you to imagine
how elephants give birth I don't know if
you've ever seen it before but they
circle around the elephant and they sway
side to side
their mom's in the center the elephant
the elephant women surround the the
elephant that's giving birth and they
create this protective Circle and they
sway back and forth because it's this
Natural Energy right when you're holding
a baby what's the first thing you
naturally do you just start this natural
sway
and so that's how it's been throughout
all of time we've always been surrounded
and these these Circles of women and uh
you know there there's that that natural
vibrational energy that moves through
everybody in the room that creates a
safe Sacred Space
and
um when we look back throughout time
about when that started to change there
was a book that was written um in the
Catholic Church
um in 1484. it was the malice malfur
Chrome I always say it wrong
um and it basically translated to the
witch's hammer and so they they brought
this throughout Europe and they
basically were saying
um at that time that the greatest threat
to the church was midwives okay so this
is when the witch trials began and
everybody always thinks of like the
Salem witch trials and that's like
really the only thing that Hollywood has
given us for the history and I call it
the her story it's really not history
it's about her
um and they they move through the
villages and um at that time there was
over nine million women that were killed
um with with the witch trial and so I
want you to think about this so in
Germany alone there was a hundred
thousand women that were murdered and
not just like midwives like it was
literally like anybody that were was
like like women would be stripped naked
in the middle of a town hall looking for
birthmarks because if they had a
birthmark it was the mark of the double
um women yeah women would be
um you know like like a man would get an
erection and say like that woman is
magical and that woman would be burned
at the stakes like it wasn't like just
childbearing women it was children it
was grandmothers it was like lots and
lots of women nine million nine million
yes this history not known why is it
exactly exactly
um and so it was a dark time in Europe
uh there was lots of famine there was I
mean if the mother figure if the
matriarch is missing of course it's
going to be dark right and at that point
there they were thinking there's not
enough uh like laborers to work so what
they ended up doing is
um women knew their fertility prior to
this it was talked about in those red
tents the average uh you know amount of
women that children had was typically
about three to four children
once that was erased and The Midwives
the herbalists the family physicians
didn't have the you know the education
that they were bringing forth of
how to know their fertility the rates
went to about 12 to 13 child children in
in one family so a mom one mom would
have 12 to 13 children which was is then
child labor right that's why child labor
laws and everything got started
and so it there was there was just
injustice all over like there was no
place that wasn't grim and awful
um and you know men would even look at
the menstruation as a streak of the
devil like it was it was definitely a
time where they were trying to I'm like
what point in history was this so it
started at 1484 this is when the book
came out the witch's Hammer
um and so it spread throughout now at
that time we started uh you know think
of Christopher Columbus right so we
started having that uh the the
immigration over to the United States
now I promise you that Native Americans
here knew what they were doing with
birth right like it was when we started
having the like westerners come over and
bringing syphilis and all this weird
[__] and their Western priest doctors
and as these um rates the population
started growing in the United States
they started to kind of come together
with the church of some sort of like
medicine like you know the practice of
medicine and medical school
um in 1700s uh women were not even
allowed to step foot into medical school
so you know think of that like any time
that you got hurt growing up any time
that you were needing any sort of
healing most people would turn to their
mom or their grandmother or you know
some female figure never a male
typically like it was like you go to get
Comfort or comforted by the female
figure so when they completely extracted
the female from medical school in 1700
it really changed medicine to a
uh profit driven controlled type of
medicine and so um you know you look
back at 1972 right that's not that long
ago and 90 of the doctors that were
entering medical school were still male
yeah yeah 500 years then since the
Extinction essentially of yeah like the
the medical medical woman yes and so
um during that time there was also the
slaves that were being brought over from
Africa
and there wasn't as much of a forgotten
history about the The Midwives the
herbalists all of that they hadn't
touched they hadn't gone there to
execute all of their witches down there
right so as these slaves came they they
had this storytelling they had the
experience of witnessing their their
Nana's and their aunties be midwives and
so this got brought into the United
States yeah these were called granny
midwives and
um the granny midwives would go and
they'd have really good outcomes you
know birth was like starting to be any
midwives so these the African-Americans
that have come over or are these just
slaves in general are like what the
African African-American slaves that
were brought over that knew and had the
knowledge of of Midwifery of you know a
female practitioner that yeah provided
practicing they kept practicing so uh in
the 1900s 19 in actually 1900 a hundred
percent of birth in the United States
were at home okay damn 100 percent
um by the time that we got into the
1930s 1940s we were looking about 50 of
births that were then moved to the
hospital so they went on these smear
campaigns with these granny midwives and
they would post ads now remember at that
time who owned the media and still does
was the Rockefellers right and they
owned the newspapers and they owned all
these things and so there would be
pictures of these beautiful
African-American women that were the
granny midwives of the South and they
would say that they were dirty and that
they were you know killing moms and
babies and don't associate with these
women and
um so the affluent people uh didn't want
to have any association with these
granny midwives and so they they said
well let's birth at the hospital and so
what ended up happening is these men
would uh go in and think that they
controlled birth right so they would lay
women flat on their back and they would
give them a drug called scopol meme
Scopolamine is an eraser so you're like
anesthetized completely out of your
[__] mind and you have no memory of
it you were you have amnesia like being
like it's like being like drugged in the
club like being drugged it's like being
roofied right yeah and so what would
happen is that these women were tied up
literally tied up to the beds okay and
their feet were put up in forceps
the doctor sat level with the with the
chair at their vagina and they would
control these births now if you can't
really tell a mom that is under
anesthesia directions you can't say push
or do this so they would wait for the
baby to start to come and then they
would go in with forceps and they would
pull these babies out
whoa cut the clock cut the cord right
away whisk the baby away to another area
put them in the nursery right like
that's all the pictures you see back
then is the dad standing smoking their
cigars looking at their babies in the
nursery where the nurses attended to
these babies
and and that was birth that was birth
that was birth for a long time I mean
I've seen Scopolamine used
um in birth in my 20-year career in a
hospital before
um and so yes they're you know the
history dates back to women being on
their backs and we know that squatting
is one of the most universal positions
for giving birth squatting increases the
pelvic Outlet by 33 percent
um but but the reason that that these
women were placed on their backs is
because they were drugged
and it was convenient for the doctor to
have them level with their feet up and
forceps now another thing that was
happening around this time is there
really wasn't universal precautions in
terms of infectious disease so these
doctors in med school were going around
and they were learning all of these
different things and they would go from
an autopsy in another room
not wash their hands come in and catch a
baby
I shouldn't say catch deliver a baby and
these women would then die of sepsis
because the person that the doctor saw
in the other room that was dead and they
were doing an autopsy on had some sort
of infectious disease that was then
passed to the women
so the darkness of this
still I mean it's still relevant I mean
we had a 40 increase in maternal
mortality rate from 2020 to 21. it's not
getting better right you know and so we
we just need to step back and go like
what are we doing wrong here like you
know like like there's there's ancient
hieroglyphics on these pyramids in Egypt
of women squatting to give birth to
their babies where did it go wrong you
know like like the advancements in
medical technology Sure Save a few
babies but and moms but like we're going
backwards now we're going backwards and
so we use that you can still save them
you can still but you can go back and
implement the practices of the normal
physiological birth or natural yeah yeah
so it's um
it's it's it's part but but let's bring
it back to this that we are the
generation that our grandparents and
that our few past Generations had been
waiting for so we get to take this
victimhood out of it right like it's
that's a that's a really dark history
her story that's that's dark that's dark
but we get a step into our power we get
to step into our worth and we get to
change this and you know instead of like
ending on this Doom and Gloom statement
I want to I want to finish with another
breath together
um and I I want this breath to be a
collective breath where we imagine tying
a red tie like a red string around us
and then out into all the other people
on this planet like there's no division
there's no reason for this division so
really quick just take a deep breath
and settle back into your body that's a
fiery topic I just got worked up with
that
and just
be present in your body
there is a beautiful Mexican proverb
that states they tried to bury us and
what they didn't realize is that we were
seeds
[Music]
and so I want you to imagine winding a
red string around your wrist
and I'm going to send that red string
right to you
but as we connect our hearts and connect
our wounds
we're also going to connect with
everyone on this planet because everyone
on this planet has had some story
that involves the beginning of Life with
violence
fear
and this is where we get to change that
this is where we get to make a
difference in our future for our
children
for our children's children
this is where we get a step outside of
the control
and realize the only control that they
have is when we're divided
so in a space of neutrality where
there's no good and no bad
I want you to just come back to your
Center and come back to your knowing and
come back to your remembering
that is it is our inherent right
to have body autonomy
to make choices for ourselves and our
families
without being controlled
in an amazing
thing I heard last week from Zach Bush
who I know you've had on the show
is that when a mama blue whale caused
calls to her baby
that the vibration of that sound travels
around the globe five times before it
dissipates
so right now I ask you all to be that
Mama blue whale
and let the energy of this conversation
reverberate around this Earth this world
this globe that we're living on
all of your sisters and all of your
brothers
to come back to your remembering
so it is so it is
[Music]
that's amazing thank you wow yeah of
course you said you had two questions I
just remembered I did I did the other
one was about
um vegan vegetarians yeah the Hot Topic
I
um you don't have to go too far into it
just like your perspective and just you
know I've heard you talk about how the
placentas look completely different so
you know just I just think that it's
such a curious space for people right
now and look I get that I mean I love
animals too but
it's kind of like an M or me and you
know I I just if I had to go kill it
myself I would struggle and I promise
you it would be a ceremony if I did
because it's not something I would want
to do but I do think that there's a a
quick sort of like overview from your
perspective and what you see with women
that don't eat meat yeah
so
there was just a documentary
Dr Paul Salcido called nourished and
um yeah he's great he's a wonderful
person extreme I love him to death but
you know like he's like like Carnival or
nothing and I'm I'm not an All or
Nothing type of human I am a person that
likes to have balance and so
um what I like to say is once we come
back to our ancestral way of eating it
was never just plants we had uh you know
gathered in these Villages and our men
would be out hunting and they would
bring back
um
whatever a bison an elk whatever it was
and every piece of that animal would be
deeply revered and used so every organ
nose to tail as we say right and what we
know historically speaking reading
through literature is that the pregnant
women were the ones that received the
the organs
um and the higher fat content of meat
because they knew that was what grew
babies healthy
um back then there was no scientific
Labs where we were making pharmaceutical
supplements supplements are just that
supplements uh supplementing to what
we're eating there was also no
scientific Labs where we were trying to
reproduce meat such as something like
beyond meat and and you know trying to
have this weird composition of God only
knows what I I call it cat food but
um those those things didn't exist it's
consumerism that's driven that right
like those those were things that never
existed before and so in my experience
what I've seen and you know it's
anecdotal there's not a lot of research
the research is is censored because it's
you look right now at who's making these
you know beyond companies yeah it is
built it is when Bill Gates is buying up
all of our Farmland too so
um when we look at it we see that
um the the best place for Mom to nourish
a baby is really back to our ancestral
way of eating and have I seen vegans
that have gone through the pregnancy and
actually eaten well not like stuff out
of a box but like really done a good job
at taking care of themselves yes like I
that's I would never say that you can't
make it through a pregnancy healthy if
you're vegan or vegetarian
but what I'd see is that most people
don't know how to eat right if they're a
vegan or vegetarian
it's it's really a lot of store-bought
junk
um heavy in carbs which then spikes
insulin levels up and sugar levels up
um in my practice I the the big like
like placental abruptions which means
the placenta detaches off the uterine
wall before the baby's born partial
abruptions have been from my vegetarian
vegan moms my full placenta abruption
was from a raw vegan
um and uh I just find that even if it's
just for baby growing that uh women if
they listen to their intuition they
usually start craving meat it's
something that happens quite often and
then I don't care if you feel like you
want to go back to being vegetarian or
vegan once you're done being pregnant do
it please by all means you know
um but but what I've seen in my
experience is that babies just come out
more robust and healthy fee and Mom's
moms do better like especially in the
postpartum they're they're well fed well
mineralized they have really good fats
going to their brain which we know
affects depression
um and it's just one of those little
nuances that uh over the 20 years of
experience that I have that that's
that's my anecdotal observation yeah
well it's a value as you've seen so many
so thank you yeah of course
have you ever read the Magdalene
manuscript it's a lot of Magdalene
energy that's that's within birth and
the the Magdalene energy is is something
that's been coming up a lot for me and
um it's it's I think it's part of the
the energy of the elevation of the Earth
right now I think that those those Ley
lines throughout our Earth right now are
being really activated and um I feel
that I have female lineage somewhere
back to the Magdalene line like I felt
that my whole entire life and Isis that
goes through Isis too it's really The
Cult of Isis that Mary Magdalene
practiced under in the mystery school
and you know I mean I'm curious your
thoughts about it all but basically the
book goes into describing it's a
transmission from Mary Magdalene through
uh through a Channeler and she talks
about her experience on
Earth with Jesus Yeshua and how she was
within the cult of Isis and they
practiced Sex Magic and like sex has
been turned into the super taboo thing
that we don't talk about it's dirty it's
all these things but it was an insanely
powerful practice and so she used sex
with Yeshua to increase his the power
the strength of his Ka body which is the
etheric sort of second body the
energetic body around you and it
strengthened him for what he ended up
going through but that was part of what
she learned in in the mystery school and
it was in in and to basically it's how
you move the energy during orgasm and
um and that it was a it's a it's a
sacred powerful practice that I don't
think we look at like that like at all
now I mean except for making a baby is
really like the kind of like some of the
magic I guess right so what do you think
we need to adopt from the lessons from
Mary Magdalene or the Magdalene energy
moving forward in the in the in that
area of
sex and you know we're talking about you
know the fact that aids is something
Bill Gates is trying to help but maybe
just don't have sex and then you have to
worry about it right so like how do we
reorient to the sacredness the the the
magic and the power of sex versus what
it's become so this goes back to birth
for me because birth in itself is a very
sexual experience
um birth can be an orgasmic experience
it's it can be an ecstatic experience
and uh you know what we look back in
history and the Catholic Church did a
really good job of halting that
sexuality
um they they said at one point that if a
mom became a woman became pregnant that
it was the doings of the devil and that
child wouldn't be considered holy until
a male priest laid hands on that child
so there's so many deep rooted shameful
things that come from sexuality I mean
that's where our woman woman magic is
that's where our power is right like the
power of moving that Kundalini orgasmic
energy through ourselves and connecting
us up into the heavens and back down
into the Earth is our power oh my God
yeah I mean look like when you move the
energy like they tell you to move it in
the book and you go up the spine up the
chakras all the way up it's kind of
freaking cool yeah I mean it's it's
intimidating for some people right like
when they first experience they're like
oh [__] I didn't know I had that much
power
um you could you could connect all of
that energy and I I know Mary Magdalene
was a midwife like she was a Divine
healer Midwife and uh you connect all of
that energy back into the spiral right
like there's that that serpent that
dances up the spine and it's always this
Divine dance and there's this sexual
energy which in essence is also birth
energy and in the weaving of the
masculine and The Feminine it's you know
there was never supposed to be a
division between the two like there's
this beautiful you know matriarchy in
this uh very egocentric patriarchy it's
supposed to be married it's supposed to
be in Balance we're not supposed to have
the division that we have today and you
know you do your research on when
division started and I know it started
way before this but the the actual
timelines of what's historically
recorded is that we look at uh when
people started like tattling on each
other when people started coming into
Villages and and executing women because
of these sacred powers that we had that
were magic and and they were all burned
you know like it's it's it's all
connected it's all connected which then
makes us scared of sexuality because a
we're we're forced to step back into our
power which we've been it's been beaten
out of us for so many years so many
generations
and then we get to realize that within
us is divinity
right we don't get to go search for it
somewhere else it's within us yeah and
so there's there's it's a lot of
different shifts that have to happen
within oneself to even identify that
these are things that
can come up and and transform us people
just don't talk about it no you find
that even with the women that you work
with who are definitely more Progressive
and in touch like do they even have a
problem talking about like what's the
conversations that need to happen around
sex to start to get comfortable with the
with with talking about it and the power
of it I think we need to step back into
we need to start with our children like
like we need our children to see the
beauty of a naked female body you know
like like I take my daughter to
um a Korean spa and everybody's naked
there you know you go to Europe
everybody's naked and my daughter sees
all these different body types and she
sees the elders and she sees the maidens
and she sees what all the different
variations of normal are that in itself
is the start of this sensuality and the
sexuality of experiencing the female
body and you know we we look at our
periods when when we start menstruating
like I remember when I started my period
I was it was like shameful I you know I
found my my grandmother who who actually
made it a beautiful experience but you
know it was like something that you
don't talk about and you hid your your
pads and your backpack God forbid one
Fallout and a boy see that you're on
your period sure or like holding a
tampon or anything yeah you're trying to
hide that stuff like you still did today
yeah so the conversation is really
missing within
um I don't think it needs to be based in
schools I think it should be based
within family units I think that we need
to talk about our basal body
temperatures I think that we need to
talk about what different stages of
discharge look throughout our cycle what
it looks like to be fertile what it
looks like to not be fertile
um and then come into the awareness and
the practice of keeping the conversation
about sexuality very sacred so it's not
just like a one-off conversation like
it's it's something that's a ceremony
like we sit down and have these these
conversations with our with our
daughters when my daughter turned 11 she
was in fifth grade
um I hosted a puberty right like for all
the girls in our class and what we went
through was was something in the sense
of
um
like a mother blessing like a a blessing
way where we all sat the mothers all sat
together in a circle and we all lit a
candle and we all spoke as we lit the
candle about what we loved about the
sacredness of our femininity and all of
these like tweens gotta sit and listen
and
um
you know they were embarrassed and
thought we were crazy but I promise you
that imprint is with them for the rest
of their life and it opens the
conversation that these conversations
can still be had further on yeah
um so there's a lot of work that we need
to do a lot
um and even with within ourselves as
adult women like we don't know like the
total extent power of our sexuality
because sexuality is not ceremony
anymore you know it's unless you
consciously make it that it's just
that's not usually our experience I want
to talk a little bit about infertility
just because I think so many so many
women struggle with it and there's
obviously so many more medical
modalities now for that I mean even
myself like I froze my eggs when I was
33 because I didn't know where I was
going with my life exactly in that area
I didn't know if it was something I
wanted to do but I was like oh let's
just like cover my bases here
um
so if someone's struggling with
fertility what things do you
recommend so the first things first is
we usually start with emotional stuff
um we go through traumas we we dig deep
into what is the fears around becoming a
mother what is the fears and and
starting a family both sides you know
both both uh male female uh it's it's
all the energy that it takes to create a
baby you have to include remember it's
like that marrying of the two Energies
so we start with the emotional side now
of course we can go into the like
different herbs to take and the you know
proper nutrition they have to help with
fertility
um but what I typically recommend doing
is is coming up with some sort of a uh
you know preconception plan like writing
a letter to your spirit baby writing a
letter with all of the attributes that
you want to you know bring with this
baby's life
stepping into a place of realizing that
you aren't this Baby's teacher that you
are this baby student and I know that's
a really hard shift for parents to make
that's a total flip total flip so
honoring that what they're coming forth
and bringing to this world into your
life is something that our deep lessons
for you
um it's there's like a lot of women
think twice about having a kid they're
like wait a minute and I'm sure all the
mothers are agreeing with me right now
oh I bet once you have it you're like oh
yeah yeah it's my greatest lessons
greatest test exactly
um there's a beautiful book called The
Spirit baby
um and you know another quick Amazon buy
and it's it's something that is is
calling that
um soul that ethereal being into your
Consciousness yeah
um these babies you know in my opinion
and again I I sit at the portal of of
life and I I sit at the portal of death
too I've helped transition a lot of
humans out of this world too and uh I
think that they they kind of wherever
they're at floating around up in the
heavens wherever it that they sit up and
they they consciously pick you know who
they're gonna
go to who they're going to interact with
um have you read the book sacred
contracts By Carolyn Mize no oh that's a
good one you'll have to read that
because it goes into yeah it goes into
us uh having these experiences here on
Earth and each person good or bad uh you
know teach us these lessons that are
deep within our souls that are what we
needed for our contract here on this
Earth and so
um you know I always say that there's a
welcoming committee and that there's a
death committee and you know I the the
first hands the first voices the first
light that gets to be in that space to
either welcome or help us hold apart are
are part of that process so there's
there's so much spirituality in all of
that and I think if you bring it back
into the infertility part of it you lose
that like it's there's no spirituality
if you're an infertility clinic and so
yeah so often I see clients that are
like oh [__] I've tried for so many
years and then they go into fertility
and they let go and they surrender the
things that they can't control and they
end the margarita baby it's when you
finally let go of wanting to have a baby
and you just go get
wasted on tacos and tequila and have sex
that night and then all of a sudden
you're like and I'm pregnant all of a
sudden it's like I guess
it's one of those stories that comes up
all the time like women finally let go
yeah or they're in the process of
adoption and then once they're matched
with a baby they become pregnant because
all the stress is gone
what do you feel
um for yourself has been you know
sort of the most important lesson that
you've learned through all of your
experiences with these women with the
energies of birth and yourself and and
um that you think about every day
it's really what's been echoed
throughout this conversation it's
um I I laugh all the time and like like
say like God [__] damn it like I've
learned my lesson in patience in this
life because that's what birth is is
patience right like I sit and wait a lot
um I have come back to the Deep
remembering within my soul I I know the
work that my grandmothers and my great
great grandmothers and all of my female
lineage has done in order for me to be
here now right like like we started the
conversation with like like they chose
us to come now and if I move away from
that deep remembering and I move away
from that surrender then I move away
from myself
and I continually remind myself in
moments of not feeling connected that
the only thing I need to do to connect
back with myself is to be back within
myself take a deep breath like slow down
like be patient embody myself be patient
surrender
um and and just know that you know
things that are happening
that I moved throughout the day with are
happening to me for a reason that's it's
that that Divine surrender trust trust
the process trust the process yeah yeah
that's beautiful wow thank you thanks
everybody for listening to the pretty
intense podcast today I hope you enjoyed
it if you like what you heard today and
you want to hear more please click on
the Subscribe button